Pékin n'a pas de leçon à recevoir de
Washington et le fait savoir
ce sont les États-Unis et pas la Chine
qui fournissent des armes sur le champ
de bataille l'approche de la Chine pour
résoudre la situation en Ukraine peut se
résumer en une phrase promouvoir les
pour parler de paix
en plein escalade des relations
sino-américaines exacerbées par
l'affaire du ballon de surveillance
Anthony blinken avait accusé Pékin de
vouloir fournir des armes à Moscou
improbable pour cet ancien militaire et
chinois sont les seuls avoir les moyens
de leur fournir un stock de blindé
lourds et de munitions intéressantes
c'est-à-dire l'émission guidée des
munitions sophistiquées parce
qu'utilisent les Russes aujourd'hui mais
d'abord ça se verrait parce que fournir
de tels matériels c'est très visible ne
serait-ce que parce qu'on en trouve sur
le terrain et je ne suis pas sûr que les
Chinois
accepteraient d'être sanctionnés
économiquement pour avoir fourni des
armes à une Russie dont elle se sent
proche et loin en même temps
la Chine n'a jamais appuyé ni critiquer
publiquement l'offensive mais Pékin a
exprimé plusieurs fois son soutien face
aux sanctions occidentales et s'apprête
à renouveler un an après l'invasion
l'Ukraine son partenariat sans limite
scellé avec le Kremlin le chef de la
diplomatie chinoise ou en Guy est
attendu à Moscou ce mardi un déplacement
qui pourrait renforcer l'appui discrète
à l'effort de guerre russe d'après le
Wall Street Journal des Entreprises de
défense appartenant à l'État chinois
exporte des équipements de navigation à
double usage commercial et militaire à
la Russie Moscou est largement
dépendante Pékin pour obtenir des
semi-conducteurs indispensables à la
guerre moderne et la startup space tea
China a fourni des imageries satellites
au groupe paramilitaire russe Wagner une
dépendance à la Chine croissante dont
Pékin tire bénéfice comme sur Taïwan où
elle profite du veto russe au Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU